vous venez de voir donc lire écouter
voir avec de très bonnes recettes de
cuisine et vous jacques e vous avez
aussi des recettes de cuisine dont la
lame et vous n'avez pas l'air très
content aujourd'hui suis furieux tout à
l'heure c'était la poule au pot lent et
4 oui maintenant les recettes de
franchise galloise sur une chose pour
les poules alors les poules c'est
uniquement bon avec manger quand il ya
une injustice scandaleuse mais c'est
vrai quand on dit un bon chien se veut
dire en gros chien un bon chat gentil
chat une bonne poule on parle de la
retire ou de la bouillie à supposer que
je dise que ce magic est une bonne jeune
femme et que ça veut dire
soyez pas vraiment pourquoi juste à
scandale c'est pourquoi il faut
réhabiliter l'épaule mais disons
qu'elles sont bêtes et ce n'est pas vrai
je vais le démontrer
d'abord deux sortes elle la poule il se
trouve que le grand père des deux toutes
nos poules tous nos coqs vite encore
rêver c'est un animal formidable
d'argent d'étoilés un coco comme ça
noir avec un grand camail rouge une
belle que tout en or super nes pas on
appelle le coq de banque qui va mais
quand on rencontre on s'écarte 1 il vit
dans sa forêt là-bas banque iva oui là
encore il ya 6000 ans quand ils ont
commencé à peupler l'asie à ce moment là
il est probable qu'ils assimilent ans
les asiatiques ont commencé à
apprivoiser des coques et des pool de
banques y va puis que petit à petit
tribu la tribu ça a gagné il ya 3000 ans
à peu près il y avait déjà des poules et
des coqs petit-fils de ce magnifique
coque de banques y va ce phénomène et
qui picorer dans les cours de ferme
lancer de celle là que je vais vous
parlez pas c'est celle là serait
intéressante et par les malheureuses
poule de batterie vous savez ces poulets
industriels qu'on abrutis qui sont
d'ailleurs devenus me diot et dont la
chair et qui mange à mano poule qu'on
dit bête sont les premiers animaux chez
qui les englobe ont découvert une
organisation sociale parfaitement il ya
une trentaine d'années on l'a découvert
ça chaque poule est capable de
reconnaître 27 autres poules
plus qu'un bébé d'un an si on vous
disait quand bébé d'un an est moins
intelligent d'une poule un bon et non
seulement elle les reconnaît
mais les classes parce qu'il ya une
hiérarchie parmi les poules en là c'est
bien un peu choquant il ya des poules de
premier rang de deuxième ronde
troisièmement et l'époux leur rang
supérieur a le droit de donner des coups
de bec ce soit appelle le droit de
piquage
donné les coups de bec à l'autre sans
claude puel et lui rendre est bas et de
manger avant tel qu'en pareilles honte
une poule le troisième rang trouve un
grain par terre comme ça elle craque
taclait retrouve un ingrat elle regarde
d'abord à droite et à gauche si elle ya
personne si elle est seule elle mangera
son grain mais s'il ya une poule d'un
rang supérieur à elle elle lui laissera
oui c'est un peu injuste
les amis des poules vous diront que ça
évite des disputes mais pas quand même
c'est un petit peu injuste
lorsqu'il assez curieux crédit à une
poule au milieu de tout ça qui a une
priorité absolue est à son premier rang
c'est la mère poule suivie ces poussins
vous savez comme c'est joli à grossir
poule avec les prochains essais petit
poucet a toujours une qui la suivent
alors celle là et là le droit de manger
avant tout le monde de donner des coups
de bec à tout le monde pourquoi pas
simplement parce qu'il ya deux choses à
faire que sur très important d'abord
défendre ses petits pilous vous savez la
mère poule par costaud une poule b si
elle rencontre un chien aussi un cha cha
proches auprès de ces petits bijoux et
fonce dessus et l'autre soit pas parce
que le très courageux elle confié plus
bon et puis elle leur apprend à vivre
parce que les petits poussins ne savent
pas par terre reconnaît être ce qui est
bon à manger séville tigres n est ce pas
alors en quoi ce geste très jolie la
mère poule qui écarte avec sépaq a
dénoncé un code patres particulier y les
poussins arrive c'est qu'elle a trouvé
quelque chose de très bien
alors bon on a trouvé cette sécheresse
durable sur la priorité de la mère poule
on l'a découvert aussi que certaines
poules quand on les sort
par exemple vous avez une poule du
premier rang pour une première catégorie
qui passe à voir tout le monde qui donne
des coups de bec à tout le monde vous la
sortie de la bombe pendant huit jours
vous la ramenez elle passe au dernier
rang il faudra qu'elle se bat avec les
autres pour revenir reprendre sa place
c'est extrêmement curieux il ya aussi
une aristocratie parmi les poules c'est
que par exemple les poules de la race
les cornes sont très très belles poules
qui sont aux noirs avec du rouge sont
toujours dominante par rapport aux
autres
alors on s'est demandé comment ces six
rondes cette aristocratie cette
hiérarchie était né parmi les poules et
on a fini par découvrir qu'il était
quand les poussait était tout petit oui
les petits pilous quand ils sont sortis
le mode erreur ils sont là suivent la
mère poule gens un peu bête qui
comprennent rien puis au bout de huit
jours il commence à prendre chacun leur
personnalité et à ce moment là il se bat
et il se bat 2 à 2 quant à franck une 30
à b et toute sa vie il sera supérieur de
bec sur les petits 32 ya eu lieu des 32
qui poussera c'est pas grave mais
laissera toute sa vie supérieure à b et
c b a battu c b sera supérieur à c'est
toute sa vie
ce moyen de cernier converium c'est
qu'il arrive
suivez moi bien que le poussin à battre
le poussins b il ne dominera b bat c il
ne dominera messi sebaâ à son tour ça
peut arriver il a été enfermé là bas tu
as alors vous avez à domine b qui domine
c'est qu'ils dominent a alors à ce
moment là si vous voulez faire une sale
blague à vos poules
vous prenez vos trois poules vous
mettiez de bretelles d'assiettes de
graines alors à arrive dans l'assiette
de graines bouscule paix puisqu'il
domine wee b arrive il bouscule ses
puisque il le domine
oui mais c'est lui qui domina alors ils
bousculent à qui bouscule b qui bouscule
c'est qu'il bouscule acquis et vos trois
poules tourneront en rond autour de leur
assiette s'avoue pas au monde qui
commencera à manger la première et enfin
toujours pour bien établir que les
poules sont pas aussi soit qu'on le dit
les poules savent prévoir le temps
beaucoup mieux que nous quand il pleut à
la campagne
bon si vous voyez les poules courir
s'abriter c'est que la pluie ne durera
pas et oui parce que ce pot besançon
mouillé puisque devrait s'arrêter
bientôt à leur espèce abrite
mais si vous les voyez rester c'est que
la pluie va durer c'est le régal de se
mouiller alors vous comprenez pas tout
de même un animal qui a une organisation
sociale qui défend la mère de famille
qui a toute une hiérarchie qui adhérent
qui sait prévoir le temps et on dit que
c'est bête
c'est un scandale voilà exactement ce
que je voulais dire il faut réhabiliter
les poules merci jacques en tout cas
c'est vraiment avec ce que vous avez dit
je constate qu'elles sont non seulement
astucieuse mais qu'elles ont plein de
savoir vivre très bien merci jacques